a lot of people think Congress doesn't
do much of anything I am one of those
people but they're working hard for you
you know what they just did they
introduced a bill to cut down on
photoshopping of models in magazines
yeah this is your government working for
you it is called the truth in
advertising act and let's get an excerpt
from the bill an increasing amount of
academic evidence links exposure to such
altered images with emotional mental and
physical health issues including eating
disorders especially among children and
teenagers there's a particular concern
about the marketing of such images to
children and teenagers and of course you
know we see this all the time my
magazines and lately there's been a
trend of celebrities that release the
actual pictures of themselves I think
Lena Dunham is sorta started this we've
got some photoshopped images of
celebrities in case you're not sure of
what's going on on these magazines let's
take a look so this is Lindsay Lohan we
just talked about lindsay that's Lindsay
to the left and that is her airbrushed
self to the right I mean without being
too glib about the segment we just did
before this she doesn't look back human
in either one of them but you can see
clearly like there's a lot of there's a
lot of alienus going on on that that
picture to the right and it's you know
clearly photoshopped and and cleaned up
and all that her eyes look alien ish
George Clooney they took some wrinkles
out and his hair has a little more
little more color guys feel free to
chime where the one after they were like
the befores the more looks great it
after looks awful is that funny they
took the salt and pepper out which
everyone's like that's the clue really
add some changes Adam's apple to make it
more manly it's slightly darker right
darkened his eyebrows to its which is
like what if he was more like Peter
Gallagher good idea but let's do it
there's some artists some we're going we
better darken his Adam's apple I mean
they literally said we need more
contouring right his Adam's apple what's
his name would not be happy about that
who got the Adam's apple removed
parishioner Bruce Jenner would not be
happy about that one more for you and we
got the best possible picture we could
find of Katy Perry and yeah I mean look
at that to the left you see a somewhat
human horse with some pores and that
chin and then they they what is this
obsession with making ever look like
aliens it's very porcelain doll it's
like I want to see someone who looks
like
they've never actually been in the Sun
ever yeah I made in his sleep in
moisturizer I can't look at that anymore
let's come back over so yeah I think
it's a great bill actually like I think
it's a really good the problem is I my
distrust of Congress means that like
what if it ever gets passed it will be
toothless and nothing will happen and
you know but then again cigarette
companies can't advertise in a whole
bunch of places they used to be able to
advertise yeah although suddenly we have
electronic cigarette advertisements all
over the place that's your time yeah
they can take that away to you I don't
sure yeah i think the bill to go far
enough really i think we should be
photoshopping people uglier i wanna say
i want to see like put more flaws in two
people that make us feel better about
ourselves that would value yeah i would
be nice really just like ruin them yeah
i don't mean to be mean i'm just saying
like I want to see uh Katy Perry with
like a big gut and bad skin and like you
know just having a horrible hair day I
would see that and not unlike a starts
without makeup I want to them to
actually create that image so what is
the for the people that read these
magazines and look at people that are
that already more beautiful than them or
richer than them and have all the things
that they don't have and then on top of
that they make them look even better
than they look normally what what is
going on like psychologically what do
you think is going awful I mean it's
creating a something to aspire to that
is fictional that literally is it does
not exist in the universe yeah and so
well right because they're starting to
look like you're starting to create a
situation where it's literally
unattainable like these goals are
unattainable and that causes perpetual
and completely complete failure it's
always going to be failure there's no
way to reach that zenith and it causes
awful mental health issues and eating
disorders and awful things I there's no
reason why we need Kate Upton to be my I
heard from a friend of a friend who was
working on that movie with Kate Upton
that they were he they were doing
digital effects to make her look like
slightly skinnier in the movie it's a
kate upton's gorgeous what are you
talking about
why do we need skinny like nobodies like
other thing about Kate Upton is how tiny
she is that it's insane well I think
there was something where promo shot
even of Hot in Cleveland where they even
tried to make Betty White look a little
slimmer and its I do but I really like
sex are up because you really have two
sexy what try to master a Betty why you
no way away from that there is a small
group of people under that do that um
but are we all doing this in our own
life too because we all have that
Instagram thing and we can blur things
and we can make ourselves look Tanner
and all that so that is is that even
more perverse that regular people I
don't think segments really minor thing
everyone's look their best I don't think
that were actually unless you're like
actually photoshopping your instagrams
which is a thing people do do that um I
mean you know I had a friend who was
doing that secretly and I found out it
was one of the reasons I cut him out of
my life and I was like this is such a
cross I was like this person is such a
fraud your Photoshop in your own is I
can't do but since like online datings
existed we're always offending our best
selves and like a perhaps a an altered
way for Taylor using angles to kind of
do what celebrity magazines yeah that
seems normal to me that's kind of just
human nature versus like actually
distorting someone's formats they look
like nothing like themselves and are
this like perfect for me just exist in
in the world by the way we have a
tremendous amount of Vaseline on the
lens here so that's a pretty damn well
right now um but to your to your point
when you started this whole thing about
Congress is there any chance Congress
like what does Congress have anything to
do with this like is this a type of
thing Congress can't do anything they
have like a six percent approval rating
they literally can't pass a law at this
point nobody likes them and this is what
they're doing is that sort of the state
of america summed up in a nutshell yes
and no i actually this is one of the
issue one of the times where I'm like
well somebody's trying to do something
that has actual impact look this I feel
like a law like this actually has much
more impact on regular america and could
have much more positive impact on
regular America than a lot of what kind
of a sense that there are that's it I
have no faith in them to get anything
done on this issue yeah it's they're the
worst they're just for any final
thoughts on congress uh yeah i mean i
don't think they have any control over
magazine do they have i mean i don't
know how this works i don't think they
can afford it
I mean most likely they're just gonna
set industry guidelines right that won't
that no one will adhere right nothing's
gonna change great so good luck with
your industry guidelines people we're
all rootin for you